Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conners, and today we're going to be discussing your
gene profile.
So these are people that have done this gene profile, and we're going to go over it together
your seed by computer screen here.
So hopefully this is, we're going to answer these questions when we go over this together.
So I'm not going to go over every single gene in this 23 and be test, but we're going to
go over some classifications of this.
It's taking a long time to go over these profiles with people, so I thought, well, we need
a little bit more education here.
I know this is a learning curve, and there's a lot to learn in trying to absorb it all in
one city.
It is difficult.
That's why I thought putting together a video will be helpful for everybody.
So let's go through this.
What are we looking for in these genes?
So this is everybody that's done the 23 and be profile.
And now have sent me the data, and once you've sent me the data, I put it into my little
handy-dandy computer program, and we get a spit out that looks similar to this.
I just took little chunkets of this that you're going to get this sheet just like this.
That's going to be about 11, 12 pages long.
And we're going to look at each one of these individual genes, and I'm going to talk about
these individual genes.
Now this is actually somebody's profile that I took their name off of.
So it's going to break it into different compartments.
But before we get to that, I want to just reiterate some of the things that I've already talked
about just so you remember that when we look at your genes, there's some things that you
need to keep in mind.
Number one, just because I have a genetic defect doesn't mean I'm going to necessarily have
a problem.
A genetic defect can be present in everybody.
Matter of fact, there isn't anybody that doesn't have genetic, single, nucleotide polymorphisms,
and they can live to 120 years old and be just fine.
Matter of fact, there's some SNP defects that can help prevent cancers, that can help prevent
different things.
That can be beneficial given different environmental circumstances.
And there's some that can cause some issues.
Now all of them will cause more issues if there's environmental insults as well, beating
that if I'm never exposed to Lyme or harmful chemicals or H. Pylori or other bacteria or pathogens,
et cetera, then my genes aren't going to really play a big part in my health.
However, if I have G defects, plus I'm exposed to Lyme infection and I'm exposed to different
pathogens.
And I have heavy metal toxicity and I was exposed to mercury in my fillings.
Then you have all these insults that lead to problems.
So when we look at this genetic profile, it's important to understand that.
That there are all sorts of environmental things that take, that play into my health, that we
take a look at the environmental things, plus the genetic issues and it can tell a picture
that we can help us manage the patient.
So specifically when we look at this gene profile, we're looking at it says variance.
So in this picture, that little blue box, you can see my arrow here, we're looking at
the HLA gene and it says variance.
In this scenario, we're looking at that it says one here and none of them say two here because
this person only has a single allele defect in these genes or it doesn't have anything in
that box.
So that would mean that this person inherit the normal, what's called a wild gene from his
mother and from his father.
He doesn't have any defects.
In this first one where it says one, that means this person inherited either a defective gene
from his or her mother or his or her father.
So this person has a single allele defect.
So understand each one of these genes, this HLA gene for instance, can be a family of genes.
In this case, there's a family of at least two genes that are measured here.
The FUT2 gene here is a family of three genes that are measured here.
Each one of the genes has two alleles, one from your father, one from your mother.
If I have zero defects, I can still have problems with the gene because of environmental insult.
If I have one defect, I could have more problems with the gene, given environmental insults.
If I have a double allele defect or two variance, I could have even more problems with the gene.
Still doesn't mean it's not going to work completely, but it means that I could have
more problems with it.
All right, so let's jump into that, so we have all those little caveats that you can remember.
We look at the HLA genes, those are the genes that are known to affect gluten,
meaning that if I have one of those genes like this person as a single allele defect on
an HLA gene, that means they're going to be more prone to be susceptible to gluten intolerance.
So if this was you, and I said you have a single allele defect on your HLA gene,
it would be my suggestion that you go gluten-free if you're not already gluten-free.
If you don't have any defects on the HLA genes, does it mean you don't have to go gluten-free?
Again, the answer is no, it would still be beneficial to go gluten-free because gluten
is inflammatory.
So if you have genetic defects of the HLA gene, it's even more important to be gluten-free.
Follow me.
So if a person was gluten-free already and they show no defects on the HLA genes, the correct
thing to do is to stay gluten-free.
If the person is not gluten-free and they have some defects on the HLA gene, that it's even
more important that they go gluten-free.
Follow me.
So the genes aren't the tell-tale for everything.
The genes just give us an indication of what's going on.
You'll understand it better as we continue.
The second digestive factor gene is your FUT2 genes.
Your FUT2 genes help make the slime layer for a better sake of a better term that coats
your intestinal walls.
So everybody knows about your flora of your intestines and you need to take probiotics so
that your intestines have a good healthy probiotic layer so you have that symbiotic environment
of microbes that help you digest things and absorb things and kill off and fight off pathogens.
So we take probiotics, that's helpful.
Well, that's good, but where did the probiotics live?
Well, they live in the gut.
Well, where did they live in the gut?
They live in the healthy slime layer that coats the intestinal walls.
That healthy slime layer is made by the epithelial cells themselves through a process using
this FUT2 gene.
So if a person has a defect like this individual, has a single allele defect, it all three
of those FUT2 genes, that's not so good.
So they are going to have more difficulty making the apartment complex for the probiotics
to live in.
So this could be a person and if this is you, you could be taking all the probiotics in
the world and you can't figure out why you can't get your gut back in order.
Somebody told me I had leaky gut, I've been taking probiotics for a long time and I still
have gut problems, it just has never gotten back in order, I still have inflammation in my
gut, my digestions off, I just can't figure out why I can't get better.
This is one of the reasons why we do these gene tests because it gives us some answers to
things.
Well then we look at your gene tests and you got a single allele or I've had people with
a double allele defect and every one of the FUT2 genes, well my gosh, no wonder you're going
to have a bad gut.
You got an out top of that, the antibiotics that you took and eating genetically modified
foods and eating junk foods and additives, calories, flavorings, things like that and you're
toast.
So what do you got to do?
You have to heal the gut.
So go back to my gut check video and understand that if you have any defects in your FUT2 genes,
you need to be on prebiotics for sure.
It's likely your whole life, be on prebiotics, be on probiotics on a long-term basis, now take
us step back.
Let's say a person has no defects here, that's the person that they might have a messed up
gut because they took antibiotics and because they had a poor diet, but it's easier for them
to recover.
So they get on prebiotics for a month or two, they start taking probiotics, their gut is normal
and they're feeling great.
Pretty much guaranteed, they don't have a whole lot of defects in the FUT2 genes.
But a person that's, gosh, I've been working on my gut for the last year and I can't seem
to get better, you probably got some defects.
Do you understand how this all comes together a little bit?
So it gives you some answers so you don't think you're crazy sometimes.
So it can really help looking at your genes and it helps you manage it.
That way that, wow, I, this person, have a single little defect on my FUT2 genes, I'm
going to need to be on prebiotics and probiotics the rest of my life, I'm going to need to watch
my diet more closely, I'm going to need to stay away from antibiotics, I'm going to need
to make different health decisions that way, helps you manage your life, let's move on.
Genetic variants, that influence histamine levels.
So there's two genes in your body that degrade histamine.
Now understand, histamine is an immune cell, or excuse me, is it a immune chemokine made
by your mast cells, that is part of your immune system.
It histamine is needed to help kill things and remove pathogens, but it's supposed to be
secreted by mast cells and it's supposed to be that degraded quite quickly, literally within
a few minutes by these specific genes.
Your ABP1 gene family, and there's one, two, three, four, five that are measured here, and
your ABP1 family, these genes degrade histamine in your gut.
So how would I get histamine in my gut?
Well histamine is an immune cell, the mast cell secreted histamine.
So there's histamines in different foods.
So foods create a histamine reaction.
So let's go back to gluten a second.
So if I'm going to eat a lot of gluten, what I have antibodies to gluten, I'm going to increase
my histamine level in my gut, and I'm going to need plenty of healthy ABP1 genes to make
an enzyme, the DAO enzyme, that degrades histamine in my gut and breaks it down.
So I don't have this inflammatory process in going out of my gut.
Now, histamine is only one of the inflammatory kibokines, so don't get me wrong.
Just because like this person doesn't really have very many variants at all, doesn't have
defects at all.
I would say ignore your histamine issues to this individual.
That doesn't mean that they're not making other inflammatory cytokines from a gluten sensitivity
because they have gluten antibodies, so that's another piece of the puzzle.
But in this case, this person has one single allele defect in one of their ABP1 genes, not
a problem.
Guarantee you, this person does not have a histamine problem.
The second gene, the H-N-M-T-G-D, actually makes the enzyme in the body, in the intracellular
or, excuse me, extracellular spaces, so that it breaks down histamine in your body, because
histamine is, that cells are related histamine in your body to kill pathogens all the time, and
the H-N-M-T-G-D is responsible to make the enzyme that degrades histamine in your body.
So if, so let's pretend, this is you, and let's pretend in the ABP gene, you have multiple
defects there.
That would tell me that you do not make DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine and you're
got very well at all.
So that my recommendation would be, you have to decrease the amount of histamines that
you consume and make sure that you're not consuming any foods that you have antibodies against.
So a Syrex pedal would probably, with a lab, would probably be in order to see if you have
any antibodies to any different foods, tested you with conhesiology, whatever we need
to do to find out, any sensitivities that you have to foods that you need to stay away
from.
And then looking at a list of foods that contain histamine, eggs, fermented foods, nuts of
all types, cheeses, things like that that have high amounts of histamine in it, that is
throwing histamine into your gut, that you don't create the enzyme to get rid of.
So you can't be eating foods that have histamine.
If you can't get rid of histamine in your gut, you will absorb it.
You will cause this histamine reaction in your body and you're going to have all sorts
of problems.
And that could be, so again, with a gene profile, you could go, wow, this is your reaction,
this is why you're so hyper and flammatory, this is why you have rashes, this is why you
have heart palpitations, this is why you've got problems, this is why you have migrates.
Those are all symptoms of histamine.
If, like in this case, this person has an HNMT gene that is, his whole gene profile is
pretty normal there, I mean, you could get much better than that.
But let's say in your profile, you had multiple gene defects in the HNMT gene.
You can't get rid of histamine in your body.
So you better not be consuming histamine so that you're absorbing it, then creating an increase
histamine reaction, and you better find out that you're not, and you haven't autoimmune
disorder, that you're going to be producing a whole lot of histamine as well.
And you need to do some things, some nutritional approaches to degrade histamine extracellularly,
meaning in the body and get it out of your body.
Does it all make sense, though?
Because too much histamine, everything in your life is a balance, everything from a biochemical
process in your body is a balance, it's all about this delicate balance.
You need histamine, it's good for you, but you need to be able to get rid of it, because
it's bad for you if there's too much of it.
So it's all about that balance, and if you have a genetic variant that doesn't allow you
to keep that balance, then you need to help manipulate that balance so that you can bring
health back.
So I get invaluable tests.
Moving on, genetic variants that may impact cell health and cell energy production.
So this set of genes helps you get nutrients into the cell, break down fats and carbohydrates
and proteins into end products to go through glycolysis and go through the crebs cycle so
that you can make energy.
You could say that you're one life's purpose, you know, you have several life's purpose,
right?
Well, write this one down.
One of your life's purpose is to make acetyl coenzyme.
So next time you're in a class and you say, somebody asks you what your life purpose is,
you say, well, it's to make acetyl coenzyme.
Later you're going to see it's to make SAM 2.
But acetyl coenzyme is what comes out of glycolysis and feeds it to the crebs cycle and
makes all sorts of ATP, if you remember, for your biology class in high school, and that is
essential for you to have energy.
Now this person has multiple defects in that area.
So in this gene that makes cartotene, acety, and the SLC gene, and you can't see that ACS
gene that I deleted, it couldn't fit on the slide down there, boy, they got a mess of defects.
So with this mess of defects they have, I could tell, without even knowing this person's
history, I could say, this person's going to have chronic fatigue.
They can't help but have chronic fatigue.
So remember I said, started off this presentation that just because you have all these gene profile
defects, if you have all these defects, doesn't mean you're going to be a mess.
However, if you've got a lot of defects, you can try to get a pretty good picture.
So in this case, with all these defects, they're going to have a hard time making ATP.
So granted, now if you add Lyme disease, or you add cancer, or you add some other dysfunction
on top of that, it's going to accelerate this problem and it just literally blow it up.
And that's the case with this individual.
They have a lot of symptoms because of that.
So they don't make a lot of energy.
So supporting this pathway with some specific nutrients is going to really help them.
So then you don't.
Now we don't.
So now we know you don't make acetylcoinside Bay.
We need to really help support that path, push that pathway, and really help that person
with their symptoms.
Does that make sense so far?
All right.
It's still with me.
I know it's a lot to go over.
I have to listen to this a couple times, and we're going to go over yours specifically.
So you'll write down your questions.
Next pathway, detoxification, kind of important to detoxify.
Remember, your level of toxicity is depended upon your ability to detoxify.
So if you are toxifying yourself at a rate greater than your rate of detoxification, you are
going to be a sick person.
So how do we know I could detoxify very well?
Well, detoxification does have to do with your genetic picture.
It has to do with other things too, where it's my stress level at, et cetera.
But we're looking at gene profiles here.
So some of your detoxification pathways are in your SOD pathway.
So the first gene that we want to look at, we're talking about detoxified, is super oxide
disretais.
I think I got another slide on this.
Let's switch to this other slide on super oxide disretais, because this is kind of important,
especially if you do it with Lyme patients.
Super oxide disretais is a gene, aptly named, because what it makes is an enzyme called
super oxide disretais.
So the SOD-T gene makes SOD, and the whole purpose of SOD super oxide disretais is to take super
oxide and turn it into hydrogen peroxide, which then turns into water, and your body excreats
it.
What's super oxide?
Well, super oxide is a byproduct of your body's metabolism.
It is necessary.
It's actually a free radical, but before you call it bad, beber, life is a balance, and
you need free radicals in your body because free radicals can help kill pathogens.
So this free radical super oxide kills pathogens, but you only want it in solution for a very
short period of time, and we don't want that to build up.
Well, it's not going to, because God made us with a gene called SOD that makes super oxide
disretais that actually will degrade any excess super oxide, turn it into hydrogen peroxide,
which other enzymes turn it into water and we peen out of our body.
Yay, we got rid of it.
So it's the cycle, this balance of life that is so beautiful.
The problem is, is what if I have a defect on my SOD gene?
What if I am a double olio defect on all three of my SOD genes?
Ooh, that kind of sticks.
Why?
Because I'm going to have a build up of super oxide.
That could be damaging to my cells, build up of super oxide, but I'm sorry, it gets worse.
If you have an excess of nitric oxide, specifically inducible, cytokine-adducible nitric oxide, it
will bind to this excess super oxide and you get peroxidite trait.
That's what circled there, the ONO-O, negative is peroxidite trait.
That is a very damaging free radical.
It's very harmful to your cells, causes a lot of fatigue, causes brain damage, etc.
This is the perfect picture of a Lyme patient, so this is what I see a lot of my Lyme patients
have.
Well, a lot of my Lyme patients are very ill- Lyme patients, so they're very ill because
they have lots of things going on.
Well, we want to blame it all on the Lyme.
Well, there's other things going on too.
It's very common with Lyme patients to see a defect in the SOD gene.
So the profile looks like this, these are the SOD genes.
This person has a single allele of defect at all three of those genes, so they certainly
have a decreased function of SOD genes, so it's not making enough super oxide dispatase.
It's keeping an excess amount of super oxide in the tissues and then it's created a lot
of peroxidite right.
Why?
Because see this Ido?
This is nitric oxide with Lyme patients.
Lyme is a chronic infection, so it's not just Lyme patients with chronic H-pylori patients,
with chronic subclinical viral patients.
They're producing an excess amount of a specific type of nitric oxide, which there's three
made types of nitric oxide.
Ited a chronic infection, you'll produce an excess amount of what's called cytokine inducible
nitric oxide through cytokine inducible nitric oxide synthase.
This will be circulating through the blood.
It will combine with the super oxide and make an excess amount of peroxidite trait.
This is what could be very damaging, and this is what causes Lyme brain.
This is what causes the achiness, the pain, that moves around in your body that nobody
conceived to understand.
Both these people, so you got two types of Lyme patients.
I had chronic Lyme, but I just took cat's call, and I'm just fine, I don't know what's
wrong with you.
They probably don't have a lot of genetic defects that we're talking about here.
Then you got the other type of person that's got a lot of genetic defects, especially in
the SOD gene and some other that we're going to talk about later, and they're producing
a ton of peroxidite trait, causing symptoms.
We want to look at these things, because you could support this pathway, and you could really
help this, so they're not getting this much of this.
There's products that can help scavenge peroxidite trait and grab onto it and get it out of the
body.
So dohy, this can be invaluable to some of these chronically ill patients.
It's just a great thing to know.
Back here, looking at this gene profile, dohy, you have these variants.
This can be super, super helpful.
Next one is glutathione production.
Let's see if it's in this picture.
You had cut it out in this corner, I cut it off, but glutathione is recycled in your body.
It's oxidized, reduced, you're recycling glutathione around this loop over and over again, and
glutathione is your primary antioxidant in your body, so it oxidizes a whole bunch of
other chemicals and garbage that you got to get rid of.
This person has three defects that are going to affect those.
Now there's single allele defects, and these are effector things, so not a horrible thing
with glutathione for this person, I've seen much worse than that.
Now as we move down, the CYP genes are your cytochrome P450 pathways.
Your cytochrome P450 pathways are essential at your primary detoxification pathway.
This person has multiple defects in their cytochrome P450 pathway.
They're going to be a slower detoxer overall, and then your pod pathway that's kind of cut
off down at the bottom of this screen is, at least right now, the research is showing.
That's how we detoxify chemicals, multiple drugs, pesticides, herbicides, et cetera, and
it's not uncommon to see a bunch of defects in that pod pathway.
People with defects in their pod pathway have to be very careful that they're buying,
they're making sure that they're buying, that the dirty dozen foods that have the highest
rate of or highest content of pesticides and chemicals and things that you should buy
organic, you need to really be really tight on making sure you're stayed away from pesticides
and herbicides and things like that.
If you have defects in your pod pathway, so again, you can see how dollars,
damage, can help make decisions in your life and it can help keep you healthy, doing pretty
well so far, not overwhelmed with you, that's okay, is it?
So again, this is just a picture of some of those pathways.
This is part of the Transalpheration Pathway right here, so this homelessness is coming from
the pathway up here through CBS's Feeding Down to Glutathione, and what's out of this
picture is the Krebs cycle and where you make your energy.
Now let's move to the Folate Pathway.
So if you're lucky enough to do this whole going over your test at my office, that I could
kind of show you some charts and where these fit in and maybe I'm the only one that fights
as fascinating, but oh well, so your Folate Pathway, the purpose of your Folate Pathway
really is to make methyl tetrahydrofolate.
And maybe one of the most researched of these genes is the methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase
gene.
That's a family of several genes, the most important is the one right down here, the MTHFRC677T
and that's probably one of the more researched genes.
And this poor soul has a double allele defect of that gene, though the research of this
gene, the MTHFRC677T, if you have a double allele defect of this gene, it's going to slow
your detoxification processes about 60 to 70%.
Now that's a very important thing to know.
This is where we get into some philosophical questions like, should I vaccinate my child?
Well, if I do, my child has a 677 double allele defect, there's a way you should vaccinate
your child.
So I don't care if you believe that vaccines cause autism or not, but using medication
as the mother.
If you do that, you had a MTHFR defect and know that since you have a double allele defect,
your child has at least a single allele defect.
If you do what your gene profile was, if the father was, then you'd have a real good
idea of what the child's is, at least you could do a little graph and figure it out.
You better make, this really should help you make some better decisions because, okay,
so here's a mom, let's use a scenario here.
A mother does her gene profile.
She knows she has multiple cytochrome P450 pathway defects in some of these other pictures
that we saw, some pod defects.
She does, she has a SOD defect, she, and this, she has a double allele defect of her MTHFR,
there's no way I'm taking medications while I'm pregnant.
You gotta figure out an actual approach to do this and there's no way you're gonna take medications
delivering this baby because you are setting this little six-pound baby up for all sorts
of disasters because they're not gonna be able to get rid of things out of their body
beating drugs, chemicals, vaccines, et cetera, very well in all, period.
And these are the kids that end up having braid issues because of choices, that medication,
vaccinations, et cetera, versus a child who's got zero defects of this, they could get vaccinated.
It goes right through them, they, you know, get out of their diaper.
There's no issues whatsoever.
So do vaccines cause autism?
No.
But do vaccines and chemicals and additives, calories, flavorings, everything can they cause
autism?
Well, if you are that slow of a detoxer, it's gonna be circulated through your body, it's
gonna cross the blood braid barrier, especially in a child where their blood braid barrier
isn't even fully formed for several years, and you think that's not gonna cause problems
in the brain, you are dreaming.
So knowing these genetic profiles can really shape the decisions you make.
This is science, this is some philosophy of a natural doctor or something like that.
Anybody that denies this is denied a lot of research.
So you have to be kind of, have your head of the sand to not deal with these issues.
All right?
This is your folate pathway.
You eat leaf, good, cooked, leafy greens.
I go through these genes all the way down here, the MTHFR gene is what we're just talking
about.
It's made purposes to make five methyl tetrahedral folate, feeds it to the MTR gene that feeds
this way.
That's not on this picture.
That's the methionine cycle, goes through the cycle of MTR, MTRR, which recycles B12, feeds
it to the methionine cycle that makes SAME.
This methyl tetrahedral folate then feeds down this way to the myopterine cycle, and this
is constantly going on in your cells.
This is feeding your cells.
Little side note, so I don't have to repeat it when I'm talking to you in person, makes
sure absolutely you never, ever, ever take folic acid.
Now, you can never, ever get away from folic acid because they put it in so many foods.
But certainly don't buy vitamins that have folic acid in them.
Folic acid is synthetic folate.
Folate is what is found in green leafy vegetables.
Folic acid is what's created in the laboratory.
Folic acid is hypothesized to be actually one of the causative factors of a methyl tetrahedral
folate reductase defect.
So the defects that we were talking about here, like this person who has a double allele defect
to the MTHFR gene, can be caused from consuming folic acid.
Now, remember, go back to some of these other genetic presentations that I've done, that
these are epigenetic defects, that some of these defects are believed to have been in the
gene pool for thousands of years, and some are protective.
Some have to do with environmental issues that our ancestors were exposed to.
These are epigenetic defects.
Some, like this MTHFR defect, is believed to be caused because of synthetic folic acid
being introduced in the 20s and 30s, that it's still in a vogue today, even though there's
literally hundreds, maybe thousands of research articles sharing the danger of using folic
acid.
Still, it's in multiple supplements.
So, it's just, stay away from it, like the plague, all right?
Next, all right, so now we're looking at the MTHFR pathway, the way you recycle B12.
So this MTHR, right there, came from right here, folate in your food, you reduce it to methyl
tetrahedral folate, it goes back to feed this pathway, it goes under the biopterate pathway,
this is what we're looking at now, feed it in right there, to the MTH pathway, another
life purpose you have that you didn't know about to make SAME.
SAME is your made methyl transferase for your entire body, so that is what helps you make
new cells, create DNA, and methylate.
When your methylation process within the cell helps you turn on and off genes that you don't
want to be on, or you need to turn on, you would remove the methyl group.
So very, very, very important.
So in this case scenario, this MTHR gene, this person has a single allele defect, the MTHR
R gene, this person has a single allele defect.
These are all the genes that feed into factors of a person needing help with vitamin B12.
Why did we add the FUT2 genes here?
Because that person has a single allele defect in all those genes, why?
Because where do you get vitamin B12?
Well you're supposed to absorb it through your gut, right?
Well where do you get it?
Where do you get it?
It's from red meat, so you eat red meat that has good vitamin B12 in there.
It binds to intrinsic factor in your stomach, and in your gut you absorb it.
Well, if I have defects in my gut's ability to create a good mucosa layer, then I'm not
going to be a good absorber of B12.
Plus, I have defects in my MTHR and MTHR R gene, so I don't recycle B12 very well.
It kind of tells us that this person is going to need to be a B12, most likely, to help
them not only help them absorb it better, but help them recycle it, so they're on a comolamide,
methyl comolamide, adenosyl comolamide, hydroxy comolamide, depending upon their symptom
picture.
Notice that that's what's necessary to feed into methionine.
Let's move on.
Then there's the PEMT and the BHMT gene, go back to this picture right here.
This is the BHMT gene right here.
So as we move through the cycle and you make methionine, again, that has to go through the MAT gene,
which we're going to talk about just a second, in order to convert to SAM.
So SAM then is your made-methyl transverse for your entire body.
Then it converts to SOH because it's all a balance.
Oh, we got too much SAMH.
We're going to make SOH that goes through the AHCY gene to a homocysteine, and the homocysteine
is shut it up.
It's recycled again through the BHMT gene to methionine to make more SAMH.
It's going in this pretty little circle that we're making SAMH as we need to make SAMH.
Oh no, we have a defect.
Well, we don't recycle homocysteine very well because why?
Because we have a BHMT defect.
Matter of fact, we got to double allele defect in two of the four genes.
Oh no, that's not good.
We're not making SAMH very well.
What's going to be the symptom picture in this person?
Well, it could be more fatigue.
This could be more even like brain fog fatigue, too.
A whole bunch of symptoms that go along with SAMH, so I don't want to simplify that.
But we have to talk about that with this person,
how could we support the BHMT pathway?
Again, we can't change the genetic picture,
but we can help support this pathway with nutrients that help push it.
Does that make sense?
And that's not the only picture.
We got to look at other things that could block it.
Does this person have a heavy metal toxicity?
Do they have a cortisol issue?
Do they have a lipopolysaccharide?
Well, what do they do?
Do they have a lipopolysaccharide issue?
Because they have a chronic Lyme, so we got to kill the chronic Lyme, too.
Is this fun?
Well, that if it's me, that's what you're probably saying.
The next, the GMT, AHCM, and the MAT gene.
We started talking about those.
This may be the most important, this MAT gene.
They certainly is for this individual,
because they have a double allele defect in one, two, three, four, five of the eight genes.
Oh, that stinks.
Yes, it does, because they don't convert with iodine to SAMH.
And we already saw that they had a defect out here at the BHMT,
so even if they are converting some homocysteine to methionine,
it's not really getting to SAMH very well.
Oogh!
Definitely need some magnesium.
Definitely need some ATP.
Of course, they don't make ATP very good.
No wonder this person isn't in my office.
No wonder they feel so gruddy.
It gets kind of frustrated, doesn't it?
Well, this is what makes my job so difficult,
because there's so many different things to fix on this person.
And if you ignore them, you ignore them to your old peril.
So you have to look under every stone to figure this out.
So that's what's so important when you deal with these patients.
You've got to look at the big picture as big a picture as you possibly can.
All right, so that's that gene profile.
Now we move into the neurotransmitters, and this is where it gets really fun.
I haven't fun yet.
Folks, isn't this exciting?
Boy, this is going a long time, and I'm trying to talk fast.
Oh, all right, so let's wide it down here.
Let's talk about neurotransmitters.
So everybody thinks about the brain with neurotransmitters,
but you'd have to have neurotransmitters everywhere, right?
Because everywhere your nerves come in contact with another nerve,
that's how they communicate through these little chemicals we call neurotransmitters.
So let's talk about these.
First one, serotonin.
So serotonin is what?
You're happy neurotransmitter?
Well, it's much more than that.
But serotonin is degraded through bow.
Let's look at it on this picture here.
This is your biopterid pathway, isn't it, pretty?
So I have to shout out to Dr. Badlidge who made these pathway planters.
Great guy.
So they came for these beautiful pictures.
I like pretty pictures, like anybody else.
So this is biopterid recycling.
Hopefully you can see my cursor here.
Biopterid goes down through fetalality, tyrosine, triptophan.
And it feeds down to serotonin down here at the bottom.
And you can see the mau down here.
Mau M-A-O is how you degrade serotonin.
It is a Y chromosome defect.
So men can only have a single allele defect.
Women can have a double allele defect.
And typically, we think of that defect.
Typically, we think a lot of these defects
has blocking that pathway.
So that is the right way to think most of the time.
But in lots of cases, it can either block or speed.
In this case, it can do that.
So serotonin is degraded through bow.
That's how you get rid of serotonin.
It makes serotonin.
We need serotonin.
But we have to degrade it.
We can't have too much serotonin.
So we have this enzyme called the mau enzyme,
which then degrade serotonin.
However, if I have a mau defect,
I can either degrade it too quickly
so that I have too little serotonin.
Or I could degrade it too slowly.
And then I have too much serotonin.
So what happens in both these people with these defects?
They have times that they have too little,
and they have times they have too much.
And here would be my symptom picture if this was me.
If I have too little serotonin, I'm sad.
And I'm maybe even a little depressed.
And I just have some melancholy,
and I have some sadness.
If I have too little, I'm a little irritable.
And I'm a little quick tempered.
And I'm a little short with people.
So I could tell a lot about you
when I look at your gene profile.
Because the next gene we talk about is dopamine up here.
And the comp gene, the COMT gene.
So dopamine, hopefully you can see by cursor.
It's on the upper right hand side.
You see dopamine.
And that's degraded through COMT.
Also, norapidephrine is,
also through mau, norapidephrine.
And epidephrine is degraded through COMT.
The COMT gene could do just the same.
It could speed, or it could slow.
But it usually slows the degradation of that neurotransmitter.
The comp defect is much researched with ADD-ADHD kids
that are seen to have in common to have a comp defect.
So they have an excess amount of dopamine.
They tend to be a little bit more aggressive.
They tend to be very stuck on things.
It's hard for them to focus.
It's hard for them to stay focused.
They get distracted, easy.
They're impulsive.
And they can be OCD.
So that is the picture of a comp defect patient.
So you add a comp defect with a bow defect
and a GAD defect.
GAD is how you create GABA.
Now you add a GAD defect.
So GABA is actually a colby neurotransmitter.
For instance, colby, you need a lot of GABA
to go to sleep at night and rest.
The first thing that has a healthy GABA production
is COMT understanding and can talk through things.
When I have GAD defects, I'm quick-tempered.
I agree.
It's hard for my brain to shell out and calm down.
And I tend to be pro-to-exiety.
So here's a person.
This individual doesn't have the bow defect.
But I have patients with a double allele bow defect.
Three comp defects and multiple GAD defects.
I could pretty much tell you their temperament.
So this gives you some answers.
Then you look at the pathway.
You go, well, how do I fix this?
Well, how you fix this a lot is by tempering the diet.
How I have a whole paper I wrote on how to balance the comp
and bow defects.
And I'm constantly adding to it.
So it's just a way to look at what feeds it.
Feedalality, tyrosine, triptophid.
These are amino acids.
Maybe it's not really good if I have a comp and bow defect
to be eaten a ton of chicken and turkey and fish and meat
and such that are going to add these amino acids.
At least don't eat them without eating a lot of fibrous vegetables.
Maybe I need to cut down on the meats a little bit and eat more vegetables.
I might do much better.
Still with me?
Because I could get more complicated.
You look at this whole pathway, this ideal pathway over here.
This is what I call the triptophid steel.
Especially in the presence of lipopolysaccharides.
What's that?
That's a byproduct of the breakdown of a gram-negative bacteria
like Lyme disease, the Bergenorphy bacteria, the Hpylori.
Iodf gamma, Todf alpha.
Those are inflammatory cytokines.
So the presence of chronic inflammation,
stress, emotional stress, triptophid gets stolen down the ideal pathway.
This is the chyuriated pathway.
Chyurated forms eventually chryllitic acid,
which could be an excitotoxin.
And this could cause depression, inflammation of the brain,
all sorts of problems.
So this is where you get an autoimmune reaction.
This ramped up inflammation of the brain,
the damage to neurons and glial cells and brain fog.
So it could kind of be a mess, right?
So in cases like this, we really have to watch the proteins
that were consumed in the amino acids that were consumed
that were not feeding this whole pathway.
That if this person has a mild defect and they're not degrading serotonin
and they have a lot of aggression,
we don't certainly want to be producing more serotonin.
Look at the bottom of this.
The bottom right-hand side, melatonin.
Ooh, that's a byproduct of serotonin.
But it's not degrading very well at all.
We got excess serotonin.
It's feeding back up here.
We got the adiosteal, the triptophid steel going on,
making chyllitic acid.
I'm not making melatonin.
That's why I can't fall asleep.
You see how this answers a lot of questions?
You thought you were just crazy?
Well, you might still be crazy.
Why you're crazy, no?
So this genetic pathway properly understood and understood
and I know nothing compared to what I hope to know in a year
is that it really can answer some questions
on why I have symptoms and what's going on.
Does this help in you?
Then you have the NOS gene that degrades and creates nitric oxide.
Remember I said there's three forms of nitric oxide?
There's NOS1 or what's called cytokine inducible nitric oxide.
That's what's ramped up in a chronic infection,
which is what's ramped up in an acute infection too,
but it's that it's supposed to degrade.
But what I have a chronic infection that I have this constantly ramped up
nitric oxide, cytokine inducible nitric oxide, or NOS1,
which can bind to superoxide if I have a SOD variant
and cause peroxidite trait problems.
That's not good.
And then there's NOS2, which is essential and important.
I understand NOS1 is important and essential,
but we don't want to have excess amounts of it.
It'll ramp up chronic infection state.
So again, it's everything is balanced.
NOS2 is found in the brain and that's protective
and neuroprotective for the brain.
NOS3 is also called endothelial nitric oxide.
The endothelial cell is the cell that lines your blood vessels.
That is absolutely essential to your blood vessels
and the health of your blood vessels.
And a deficiency in NOS3 or endothelial nitric oxide
is your cause of high blood pressure.
It leads to cardiovascular disease.
You add that to these additional cardiovascular support genes,
the ACE gene.
I use this person as a defect in the ACE gene.
This person is really going to be prone here
to high blood pressure and cardiovascular disease
and needs support in that area.
So this person, this very person, I can't remember.
But they could say, well, I don't have high blood pressure.
Well, you don't have high blood pressure.
You don't know you have cardiovascular disease,
but you definitely don't make as much endothelial nitric oxide
and you have issues with your ACE genes that make
the receptor that will decrease your blood pressure.
We certainly want to support that or read it out
before you end up having a problem.
Does that make sense?
So knowing these things prior to having a disease
can be really helpful in helping you make decisions
to help monitor your life.
This next gene is also really, all these genes are important,
but this one is really important, especially if I can't see patients
in cancer patients.
This vitamin D receptor gene, this VDR gene,
there's three genes that we measure in this gene family.
And this person has pretty shot here.
They got a single allele defected two of them
and a double allele defected one of them.
So this person does not make that,
they have a difficult time getting vitamin D
where it's needed into the cell, into the bone.
They don't have as many receptors.
I remember the vitamin D receptors also function as an apoptosis receptor
to help prevent cell not going through apoptosis,
which leads to cancer.
So I want my patients that have this gene defect
to have blood vitamin D levels,
if they measure their vitamin D levels, certainly over 80.
In fact, if you had it over 100, I'd be much more happier
because they need to have much higher vitamin,
circulating vitamin D levels, blood tested vitamin D levels,
because they have a receptor defect.
So with this gene defect, you want to really op your vitamin D levels.
If you haven't gotten a test, you can get your vitamin D blood tested,
not a very expensive test.
But this person certainly needs to be on 5 to 10 to 15,000
I use a vitamin D a day.
Is this helpful so far?
All sorts of things to learn about your gene defect.
And then this, my computer program puts this,
this BH4 is biopterid.
Biopterid has to do with your mood, has to do with your nitric oxide too.
So let's go back to this pathway here.
Biopterid recycling, so biopterid is recycled here,
and it moves around this cycle like this,
feeding, creating neurotransmitters,
creating nitric oxide.
See, this is E and OS, that's NOS3, same thing,
endothelial nitric oxide here.
And it's so important for your heart,
it's so important for your neurotransmitters,
it's important for your brain,
it's just really important, isn't it?
So defects in that affect your mood,
it also affects your heart,
so important cardiovascular features.
Still with me?
Is this fun?
Well, we're at the end.
So at the end that after I go through all of this with you,
I figure out, based upon your ratings on all those genes,
a protocol for you.
So your protocol is based upon those genes,
I decide what we need to do,
to support those pathways.
I can't change the genes, but we can certainly support the pathways.
It has to do with your personal symptoms,
as well as what's going on with your gene profile.
So in this case, we're going to use a protocol
B-specific, and a B-specific,
that specific vitamin has your B-support
without the methylation support,
because we can't support methylation first
with this person because they have so many defects
in the biopterant pathway,
that if we push methylation too hard,
this is what we see a lot with patients,
they come in and they're taking something
that because they'd ran one gene test,
and they have an MTHFR or G defect,
so the doctor put them on a high doses of methyl tetrahedral folate,
and that's not a good way to do it,
because if you have other G defects,
don't because they had all that circulated
five methyl tetrahedral folate,
it pushes everything else.
And this person had a ton of defects in the biopterant pathway,
you can't add methylation support right away.
So we're supporting their cell health
because of the issues with fatigue,
and the issues with their ability to make energy.
That's why we're giving mitochondrial support.
You need minerals for all those pathways,
and we're supporting SOD,
because one of the biggest problems this person had
was brain fog and brain fatigue
from excess proxy nitrate.
So remember, that's from an SOD defect,
so we have to support the SOD,
and I could have used a proxy nitrate scavenger
with this person too,
but I don't like to use too many supplements at one time,
and we just want to make sure things are going,
and we have to tweak this and play with it,
and it's not something that they're going to be on
the rest of their life,
it might be there only going to be on for a month or two,
and we need to change things.
So what's hard when you have genetic defects,
it's affected so many pathways,
so you have to tweak the program.
It's not like here's this cookie cutter thing,
it just doesn't work that way.
So you have to be patient with yourself,
and that's how we'll all be happy
because you're a person
and your body's changing all the time.
So if you have questions,
if you're watching this video,
you don't even know who I am.
My name is Dr. Cameron Cutters,
and that's our website Cutters Clinic up there.
So if you somehow stumble across it
and stomached your way through it,
I congratulate you.
If you want more information about our clinic,
you can contact us.
If you're watching this video,
most likely I made you watch this video,
and if you're still here,
I will give you a cookie
because you watched the whole thing.
So good job.
If you need to watch it a couple times,
do so.
And I look forward to talking to you about your test.
Alright, thanks.
Bye-bye.